et là 31 ans un salaire d'ingénieur
et vit dans le sous-sol de ses parents à
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu c'est ce que je
trouve chemin aberrant parce que je suis
vraiment privilégiée j'ai un bon emploi
j'ai un bon salaire des bonnes
conditions pour moi ça fonctionne pas
parce que je veux pas non plus trop
m'endetter avec la flambée immobilière
de la pandémie et 8 hausses consécutives
du taux directeur le rêve d'Audrey
Blouin Rousseau d'accéder à la propriété
semble de plus en plus inaccessible si
ça se scampe pas
vraiment retourner en appartement qui
dit moins d'acheteurs dit aussi moins de
construction
car les taux d'intérêt élevés
refroidissent aussi les promoteurs
immobiliers sans parler de la hausse des
coûts des matériaux et de la main
d'oeuvre on a un problème d'offre de
logement à Montréal et la seule façon de
résoudre ce problème là c'est en
construisant des logements et en ce
moment on a pu ce qu'il faut comme
stabilité économique les gens sont un
peu exaspérés de toutes les hausses de
taux directeur donc ils veulent aller
chercher une au niveau des paiements
reçoivent beaucoup d'appels de clients
pour convertir des taux variables en
taux fixes parce que ce sont eux qui
paient le plus depuis le début des
hausses environ 1000$ de différence sur
le paiement pour une hypothèque de 450
000 dollars donc c'est énorme les
ménages non d'autres choix que de couper
dans les dépenses comme la nouvelle
voiture et les concessionnaires et cops
mettent un peu leurs projets à l'été
voir si le taux vont redescendre le
paiement des fois ça double ça monte de
500 dollars par mois des baisses de tour
ne sont toutefois pas encore dans les
cartons de la Banque du Canada dont
l'objectif demeure de calmer l'inflation
entre temps c'est la détresse que
ressentent des gens en comme Audrey je
trouve ça dommage plus jeune ma
génération parce que j'ai des amis qui
sont dans la même situation que moi je
dirais qu'il y a beaucoup de détresse et
qu'il faudra apprendre à apprivoiser ici
Jaco de Richard benour Radio-Canada
Montréal